yeah are you
ready all right so are you Christian oh
sure I am why is a born again Christian
or
Catholic I'm a Christian I'm a follower
of Jesus so you believe Jesus to be God
oh absolutely otherwise I wouldn't be a
Christian in the Bible you see clearly
that Jesus come be God in the Bible are
you aware of Mark
13:32 that says what Mark 1 you aware of
it that says what okay Mark 13:32 we
Jesus ask about the
hour when Jesus ask about the hour he
said no one knows have you got any more
talking points because this is a very
expired question Christians
have over and over and over knows the
day and
the you need to have to some you need to
have something the first time I meet you
you tell me God love you and allow me to
finish my point have you been here
before I've been here after as well has
this question been answered here no they
haven't answered it that's not true
that's I'm going to see if you can
answer it not coming to the conver with
good faith this is a question the
question of how can God not know
something is a question that has been
answered over and over and the answer is
very simple it is in the fact that Jesus
Christ came into this world all right
and there's something in the because if
you're going to be looking at the
scriptures if you are quoting the Bible
I'm not interested in talking to anybody
about the Bible if they don't actually
believe the Bible if you are choosing
what you think is true in the Bible and
then you will not believe other things
that are said in the the Bible then we
cannot be using the Bible to have a
conversation so if you're going to be
talking the reason I don't talk to
people about their book like I'm not
going to be talking to you about what's
in your book because that's not why I'm
here I'm here to talk to you about
what's in my book I'm here to talk to
you about what I believe in I'm here to
talk to you about what is in the Bible
because that's what I believe you come
up every time you talk about the Bible
but you don't believe it because when
you qu when you quoting scriptures you
will quote one verse sometimes the
answer to what you are looking for is in
the exact next verse but because that's
what you've been taught you don't even
know it so if we are going to do the
Bible let's do the Bible because we
believe it but if you don't believe
everything the Bible says then don't go
at all into anything the Bible say so
you fin so that's why I don't talk about
your book and I don't think you should
be talking about mine because you don't
believe it but you accuse me of many
points address it do you believe the
Bible step by step so are you saying
Jesus when he was in Palestine in order
to speak to someone he has to believe in
Jesus first or you to speak to people
they never believed in him so your
condition is invalid because Jesus
himself likewise Isaiah Jeremiah they
were never going around saying people
believe in us then we can speak to you
you have to discuss with me
intellectually logically to see what you
claiming about your book cuz if you
claim your books from God and I'll show
you discrepancy and contradiction you
cannot tell me I'm not going to explain
to you until you believe it in my book
it's called Blind following that's why
the beauty of Islam Islam when IT
addresses the people it address just
them with intellectual rational tangible
prove what Islam is the truth doesn't
not tell them become Muslim first then
we tell you what Islam is the truth that
is a paradox so your argument is ask of
respect that you say it's been answered
it's not been answered because why you
so out of the Bible very well the the
fact that Jesus you claim he's God all
the time doesn't know the hour which
deficiency cuz God know everything all
the time regardless even if he's going
to become a
tree still have the attribute of knowing
everything all the time the fact that
Jesus didn't know the hour the fact that
Jesus said I'm going to my God and your
God that is sufficient to show you what
you believe about Jesus is incorrect I
don't have to put the whole bottle of
poison in your water to poison you I A
Drop of Poison is enough okay so I'm
going to ask you a very simple question
um why was Jesus killed according to the
Bible he was killed because the the
Romans and the some Jewish people
accused him that he said he was God
which is not true because Jesus himself
in the Bible clarified himself when they
said to him are you claiming to be God
he said the next passage if you read the
next passage he said is it not written
in your book that I call you God and if
you go to the Old Testament God called
theud the the Israelites judges Gods so
in the Bible someone complete
misrepresentation because I know theage
talking about in John 10 according to
the logic of the said Jesus was exactly
saying the exact opposite of what you're
trying to say this is why I keep saying
that if you're going to be quoting the
Bible at least you should understand
what you are saying before you let's get
the Bible okay for you because you want
to get the Bible to show you that Jesus
himself himself is weak he's not weak
I'm that's what he said he say speaking
weak I'm speaking to him listen let the
man look African speaking to each other
anyway listen afri this about the truth
not about
AF
many so so I I just told you the first
thing I told you is that the question
every you what he doing he's following
the belie of the ROM he's following the
belief of the Romans who thought that
Jesus was God Jesus himself clearly let
me ask you a clear question does God
have a god you said what does a God have
a
God does a God have a god
Jesus Is God speaking to him listen
because he's a free man I'm a free man
stop this mindset we're not slaves
anymore we are
free what are you talking
listen
the J in the Bible said I'm going to my
God and your God he just told me God
doesn't have God if Jesus was God he
should have no God the fact that Jesus
have a God he cannot be God even accar
we are notarian we are notarian that's
because I told you exactly the same
thing that there is something respect
respect have you ever heard of the
Incarnation have you heard of the
ination have you heard of the
Incarnation if God is God people now you
you killed us you enslaved us we're free
now not me personally me
person God is God stop that's the
problem of the mindset of the slave the
slave
mind you going let
are you going to let me talk or sorry
forgive me all right so I do not believe
in
the the model that you are trying to use
in order to define God because when you
quote scriptures then you must
understand that scriptures has its own
there's a self revelation of Jesus that
is given in the scriptures so when you
choose when you pick and choose you are
not coming with good faith so everything
you have said for instance oh Jesus did
he say I go to my father and your father
my God and a God yes but how was he
speaking he was speaking in virtue of
his humanity and the Bible reveals that
Jesus is both Divine and human when when
when the Bible says that the Word was
God and the Word was made flesh and
brought amongst us it would have been a
lie if Jesus Christ was not having a
real human experience and in order for
him to have a real human experience then
he had to take upon himself the
attributes of humanity while holding at
Bay his divinity so and there's no
contradiction in that there's no
contradiction in that so actually the
god of the Bible is the real God because
he's the only God that could have become
human and it is not a deficiency it is
actually the superiority as opposed to
the god that is revealed in your book
you have a God that cannot become a
human I have a God that if he chooses he
can become a human and have a full human
mention many points he what he said is a
paradox you know why because he said
that Jesus was a human and a God the
same time okay it's like basically
telling me someone was perfect and imp
when I was speak I listening
to allow him to finish the same way we
allow to do his not an imperfection it's
not an imperfection to a
human expecting the
he said he saides
Imp in the Bible he said Jesus was God
and man at the same time it's called a
paradox you know why because if someone
is perfect all the time it's illogical
impossible irrational to be imperfect in
any time the fact that was he was
imperfect in certain time that will
invalidate he's perfect all the time
it's a logical
rational your
iway Jus Jesus said over me I doing
thatl
respect the Jesus said I'm going to my
God and your said nature is God Jesus
categories you missing is a category of
humanity and
div a real human experience is not
imperfection there's
something someone had take care of
himone that's consistent with being
human how you believe God someone church
is not he believe God someone is
not he said that God can do everything
but you could become limited because
human are limited become lied impect
that's good become limited is that what
you think that's good become limited
your God into creation God is Li your
God is
does
become be
liit we lied God be limited
his Christianity is dying in the world
that's why CH that's exactly why that's
exactly
why because chrisan believe
why you believe he got in need of no one
he got in need of no one
Allah
[Music]
beet to be quiet time to be quiet any
you running
very simple I want to leave you with a
simple
simp tonight I dare you before you sleep
tonight to
Jesus in need of God in the I can't do
nothing
myself scar of the Romans God scared of
the Romans imagine God scared of the
Romans imagine my sisters ladies and
gentlemen God scared of Romans Allah is
the all powerful become a baby someone
CH that's why
Christianity that's why
Christianity are you talking are you
asking are you talking are you
asking my dear brothers and
imagine imagine
God imagine God someone SL in the back
Allah is one unique self-sufficient
Master to Allah Allah is perfect Allah
is Allah is perfect
[Applause]
Jesus
anyway anyway my dear brothers and SS
these two
people anyway imagine we spoke in the
language Prophet Muhammad spoke that
spoke in English she never
[Music]
English done so Jesus didn't know
English mate it didn't Arabic we never
claimed he did didn't even claim he
did
magd that's why we need to speak about
Allah you
know Round Round Up to round the up my
my dear brothers and sisters to round
the up Christianity is dying in the
west they can we will reading I give you
example if Prophet Muhammad come back
now he will see us with the book that he
was using if Jesus comes back he will
have no clue about the New Testament he
doesn't know it he doesn't know the New
Testament but we are teaching from the
same book that Prophet muhamad
alhamdulillah conclusion the conclusion
they're done
done private private private